nick swisher kind enough to join us on
the line
Fox Sports Major League Baseball analyst
and Nick Dan Haley here filling in for
rich on the Rich Eisen show I'm just
reading this Newsday article among the
Yankees players coaches and staff with
lockers in the visiting Clubhouse were
two extra members of the traveling party
with the Yankees Reggie Jackson and Nick
Swisher dude living in a dream world bro
for real soaking up every bit of this
I'm telling you man just to be part of
the organization again some place that
feels like home to me to have Brian
Cashman house time rather want me to be
in that building with them each and
every night brother it means the world
to me that is amazing and now your guys
set to take on the Astros in the ALDS
Game one saturday night at 8:00 on Fox
third time in five years
Astros and Yankees have met in the
postseason this is gonna be good this is
this is the two best teams in the
American League this is power on power I
mean when you saw that this was gonna
happen the Astros I'm sure you said okay
let's get it on right I could have told
you this in April that this was going to
happen I'm telling you I think it is the
top three teams in baseball only two
remain I mean obviously the Dodgers with
a heartbreaking loss but now if you look
at this schedule I mean you got the
Nationals in st. Louis and this isn't
taking anything away from those two
teams but if you want to watch the World
Series this ALCS this is going to be
your World Series though there's no
doubt I mean the Astros polished off the
Rays last night behind Gerrit Cole
headed to the American League
Championship Series for the third year
in a row Cole has been absolutely
insanely dominant 25 strikeouts and
back-to-back games in the division
series you kidding me when you watch
them what are you thinking how filthy is
that guy I'm thinking to myself man I'm
glad I'm not playing anymore I can
guarantee you that this guy right here
man not only that not only the stuff
that he has but the confidence that he
has I don't know if you saw the presser
before game five it was obvious on that
workout day and they were asking him
what's your mindset what's your
preparation and he was just like you
know just as
I would in the other stars I mean this
guy is so confident he knows exactly
what he's going to do I mean let's be
honest man 20 and 5 on the season the
best pitcher in baseball from the middle
of May all the way to the end of the
season and continuing in the postseason
man 2 and O doing his thing and how nice
is that for the Houston Astros to lose
Game four in Tampa to could be the side
Young Award winner Justin Verlander and
be like man no big deal baby we got
Gerrit Cole to back him up in Game five
so at home he's been absolutely dominant
on the road he's been dominant the
Houston Astros I mean you know me man I
bleed pinstripes and our group for the
Yanks each and every day but they're
gonna have their hands full with this
Houston Astros lineup yeah Cole 18 and
OH in his last 24 starts and like I said
it really is the power versus Power it's
the pitching staff the Astros against
the home run power of the Yankees the
Yankees set that homerun record this
year you're gonna see Verlander and Cole
twice each if this series goes seven
games you have to get one of those right
you have you have to beat those guys at
least one time to have a chance which
one do you which one of the Yankees have
a better chance to beat Verlander Cole
it's hard to say man both of those guys
will finish one two and the siyoung
depending on whether it's Verlander Cole
or it's called Verlander I think the
best thing that the Yankees have going
for them now is that the Rays did take
them five games they made you know which
other point land to throw an extra
hundred pitches they made Gerrit Cole
throw and I was I think 103 pitches he
threw last night and by the way man he
was chomping at the bit to get back out
there the ninth inning he wanted to
close that down for himself I think the
best thing that the Yankees have going
for themselves right now is it that
Greinke is going to start Game one right
you're not gonna face Karen Cole Game
one you're not gonna face Justin
Verlander Game one because let's be
honest after you're done as a hitter
after you're done facing those two
flamethrowers back-to-back days this is
taking nothing away from Zack Greinke
because he's a cyborg winner and he's
amazing and he's making like a hundred
million dollars this year but when you
see 98 on the board consistently
back-to-back days and then on the sudden
you see 92 boy I'm breaking my ankles
trying to get in that batter's box so I
think that Greg he's gonna have to do a
good job of keeping the ball down in the
zone he's gonna have to
okay because now he's really kind of
reinvested himself he doesn't have the
power stuff that he's always had and I
think that's a tough spot to be in that
rotation when you go from two flame
throwers down to kind of like a UH I
guess more of a surgeon I guess you
could say more kind of slicing and
dicing on the corners he's definitely
going to have to be on the corners and
low in the zone because if he misses in
the middle part of the plate especially
in that Houston ballpark there's gonna
be a lot of home run fit yeah much more
surgical for Greinke than he's been in
the past Yankees and Astros have
combined for 210 wins the force fourth
most combined wins all-time by two teams
meeting in the postseason give me a
couple X factors one for each team Nick
well I think error judgment I mean
obviously the best player and one of the
best teams he's gonna have to bring his
game I think right now there's a couple
roster decisions that are being made I
think Aaron Hicks is kind of being
thrown up in the air kind of if he's
gonna be able to come back and do his
thing
also CC Sabathia obviously wasn't on the
roster in the ALDS I think that you're
probably gonna see him on the ALCS just
because of those power left-handed bats
they have in that lineup right you know
Sabathia is not going to be the starting
type of guy but you could bring him in
to face guys like Brantley a guy like
you were gone Alvarez okay let's be
honest man I mean that that lineup
there's no holes in it 1 through 9 these
guys are bringing Thunder each and every
at-bat especially when you got in my
mind the MVP candidate Alex Bregman in
the middle that lineup I'm telling you
what man there's a lot of things going
good for the Astros but there's also a
lot of great things going for the
Yankees man this is that heavyweight
fight we've been waiting for since April
I can't wait to get it going know you're
a hundred percent right about that Nick
Swisher 12 year Major League Baseball
veteran World Series champion on the
line currently working for Fox Sports is
a major league baseball analyst Dan
Haley here on the Rich Eisen show
filling in for rich who's over in London
Nick let's look at the NLCS now I'm just
gonna come her out of the gates and tell
you I'm a DC native I'm a huge Nats fan
I was there game 5 I went down in the
locker room just to kind of see what was
going on literally to soak up a little
champagne along the way I got home my
wife is like what happened to you I said
I didn't even do anything I just wanted
to watch and I told my buddies and I was
driving home I said if we get pulled
over we're gonna be in trouble cuz I
smell like [ __ ] man hey good thing I was
riding on the bus cuz I smell just like
you the celebration in Minnesota I think
there's just a lot of great things going
over in our nation's capital right now I
mean let's be honest you get rid of
brights are for one of the best players
we have in our game and you finally win
that first series in playoff history for
the Nationals man I mean like as a fan
and as a player you could not be more
proud of your team I mean just from
where you guys were at the beginning of
the season to where you guys are now I
mean let's be honest man you know you
got written down in my opinion I mean
MVP votes for sure and the way Stephen
Strasburg has pitched down the stretch
for you guys man I was so impressed with
the way he's handled himself because
I've always kind of heard that rap on
Strasburg that if he doesn't feel
healthy or if he's a little banged up
he's not going to be the guy that you
need but I'm telling you what man he's
shutting a lot of people up nowadays
because he is out there doing his thing
Mad Max is gonna be there at the end of
the day and let's be honest man I mean
you have enough faith in a guy by the
name of Anibal Sanchez to start Game one
in the NLCS for the first time ever in
your organization's history I'm telling
you what man there's a lot of great
things going over there Trey Turner's
doing his thing the straw that stirs the
drink I don't think there's a lot of fun
things man it's obviously a
heartbreaking loss for the Dodgers and
it's kind of shame not to see them in
that NLCS but for two great baseball
cities st. Louis and our nation's
capital baby going at it man I'm excited
to see who ends up winning that period
yeah living here in LA and being you
know in a sea of Dodgers fans as I'm
watching that game and the Howie
Kendrick you know Grand Slam happens and
my jaw just drops and I start looking
around like is it okay to cheer damn
right it's okay to cheer I mean this is
moment and you mentioned and then that's
19 and 31 in late May essentially
they've been playing elimination games
since then do you believe that that that
that actually carries over that that
momentum carries over or is every series
a clean slate no I think there's a lot
of good things going over there I think
that they have had their back up against
the wall since May I mean let's be
honest man I don't know about you but me
being in the media
we were calling for David Martinez his
job in June right like men
this guy's not the guy he's not the
leader we thought he was boy was I wrong
I'm he talked about putting your foot in
your mouth in my mind this guy could be
the manager of the year the fact that he
took that group of guys and really just
got them moving in the right direction I
mean let's be honest man they had the
chance to sign Bryce Harper Mike Rizzo
said you know what that's a little too
much money for us and it ended up paying
off I tell you what man I know you
didn't sign Bryce for that 3:30 but you
might have to sign Anthony Rendon for
that 300 man what an amazing season he's
had
like you said Howie Kendrick with a huge
grand slam he's been a professional
hitter from the day he showed up in the
big leagues I just think there's so many
great things going on for that
organization win or lose for these guys
right now I'm telling you man it's been
an unbelievable season for them hats off
to them
yeah and the Cardinals obviously have
had a pretty good season as well you
know they have the fifth best bullpen er
a 3.8 two you look at the Nationals
bullpen historically speaking it's the
worst bullpen in postseason baseball
history I mean they're there er a for
the bullpen almost three full runs
higher they have two reliable relievers
right now and Sean Doolittle and Daniel
Hudson and unlike unlike the NLDS you
can't you're not gonna be able to roll
Strasburg and and max out there in
relief are you in a seven-game series
you're not gonna be able to hide you're
got to use more of these relievers than
you use in this short series in the
division series
oh yeah hundred percent if there is an
Achilles heel from the Nationals it's
definitely their bullpen I mean that's
been noted all year long as a matter of
fact that's probably been noted for the
last five or six years they just haven't
had that big name closer that's been
able to go out and shut games down for
them obviously they brought over Sean
Doolittle from Oakland and he's done a
decent job but I think what helped them
out in that short series was them to be
able to bring out certain guys right to
be able to bring out Max Scherzer in the
eighth inning of one game right to be
able to bring a Strasburg in the
wild-card game to say hey man come in
here and give us four innings out of the
bullpen because if you can use those two
guys in the bullpen I mean obviously
you're gonna be a lot better but with
the seven game series
you have to use everybody this
where the depth of your team really
shows and right now if the Washington
Nationals want to see themselves beat
this hot st. Louis Cardinal team that
bullpen has to be on point for sure most
important Cardinal in this series is
going to be who yadi Molina no doubt
about it man he's been a rock star since
he showed up in the big leagues first
ballot Hall of Famer captain of that
team the man that gets that pitching
staff to do what they're going to do and
I don't know if you saw it but they came
out with their rotation they're going
with Michaelis and Game one and then you
know they got Flair or they got
Wainwright the veteran in Game two then
they got Jack Flaherty bro who is
absolutely dominant could you imagine
walking out in the NLDS winner-take-all
game five and you take the mound in the
bottom of the first inning and it's 10
nothing I think that's about feeling
good about yourself
Jack Blair he's one of those kids and
I'm gonna steal a quote from one of his
teammates and it's not a matter of when
he's gonna win he's gonna win us all
young it's a matter of how many songs
he's gonna win so right now I think st.
Louis is that baseball town that sees
themselves back in it my caddie Scott
Ebro has been calling me for the last
week saying man World Series champs st.
Louis Cardinal 2019 and right now man
they look pretty good your caddy and
you've been playing like here traveling
with the Yankees what's going on oh yeah
yeah I haven't gotten all the links as
of lately but a man I'm a loyal guy bro
you don't saying I gotta have my guy he
knows my game you don't I mean I gotta
take care of my guy you know let me ask
you this because I had this conversation
all the time with my buddies
proper tip now cuz I know clubs are
different right sometimes there's a
caddy fee that's included but let's say
I go into a visiting club proper tip for
a caddy he's walking with your bag
you're not writing is what for sure I'll
just do that you know especially out in
Los Angeles man I mean price of living
out there is a little more expensive
then it wasn't my hometown of
Parkersburg West Virginia so I'm
learning man slowly but surely you know
I mean I'm learning my golf etiquette
but I think just right now man you know
just being able to be home and you know
just still spend time with my family
obviously do some amazing things like
travel with the Yankees try and bring as
much as I can to the table for them I'm
telling you well bro like I said man I'm
living in a dream world bro it's been an
absolute blast these last couple years
retirement has been amazing and I'm just
loving it right now
well you're doing a good job on TV I
certainly enjoy seeing you with one of
my counterparts in NFL Network amber
Theo Harris do you how great she's one
of the guys it's amazing yeah it's so
fun to work with do you wake up with
this much energy or do you have to drink
like six Red Bulls I have not met you in
person swish but we're gonna have to
hang out maybe a little golf in LA here
one of these days cuz that be amazing do
we say we make it my boys Brock and
awesome bro I know Richard absolutely
one of the best in the game but you two
guys on the back end of it bro really
make this show what it is Matt be good
go Yankees Thank You Nick alright for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app